[Music]
let's go to
becky in austin texas what's up becky
and austin
hey dr john just setting down the bricks
all
you know i have been following you from
the beginning you and a.o talking about
what your podcast name was going to be
and
you and your team have just helped me so
tremendously with personal growth so
hats off to you guys you have a guest
thank you so much
the purpose of my call today um
my son-in-law of two and a half years
threw a grenade into the middle of trust
i had in him with infidelity
and i'm struggling you cheated on your
daughter
yeah
and i'm struggling
with how to handle a conversation do i
have a conversation do i not have a
conversation i know that it it's their
thing and i'm not in it
um i've shared with my daughter quite a
few of your podcast segments um
explained to her
after i mean i was just so mad i'm so
mad
and um
she was devastated i was devastated but
you know i said these things happen and
it's part of life and you can grow past
it you can grow together
but he's sick and he needs some help and
she she knows that and he knows that
um
and i haven't seen him and i knew at the
time i was so mad don't talk text or
type man just stay stay away because i
didn't want to say the wrong thing um
but i i'm gonna see him you know and i
don't want it to be where it's this
elephant in the room that no one talks
about
but at the same time i don't think
there's anything i can tell him that he
doesn't already know
i don't want to lay
guilt and shame and
i just don't know how i don't know how
to approach it
oh man well thank you for being here
thank you for being the single most
mature mother-in-law i think i've ever
talked to on this show
that's incredible
it's because of you yeah right um
no there's a lot of mature
mother-in-laws that call but like your
wisdom here is incredible is this
incredible thank you um
i'm trying to think of where to start
here relatively like i i instantly know
where i want to go with this but i want
to circle around it just for a second um
what was your relationship with this
with this young man before this
um
you know
they
they were together for about a year
before they got engaged um he was not
from our from our town the area where we
live so i didn't know him i did not know
his family
i've noticed
you know he's always welcome in my home
um
i felt like i had a good relationship
with him but i noticed
that i i think he was uncomfortable ever
being in the same room with me by
himself okay i noticed that if it you
know if my daughter left to go they have
a they have a little toddler um
if she went to go ten to the baby he he
would get up and kind of follow her
and i always would ask him how's your
work you know how's your family just
kind of you know scratching the surface
and just general conversation but no
in-depth deep conversation with him ever
i know
he's had a lot of issues growing up and
his family lots of dysfunction um
with this same infidelity issue so i'm
kind of connecting all the dots
he knows it's wrong
he swore he would never do it and then
he did you know and i'm like okay
um
so the only relationship you can
impact is your relationship with him
and so i i want you to spend your energy
not trying to fix their marriage or to
become a marriage
like have a radar for their marriage
they're going to have to figure that out
i also think it's wise at some point and
this is going to be really tough
um
for your daughter to have another
confidant other than her mom when it
comes to deep marital issues
yeah and i just to speak to that she um
she texted me he
he's working like five hours away
and she text me out of the blue and said
hey can you watch the baby this weekend
i'm like what what's going on and she
said well i just i need to go you know i
need to go
see my husband
and
but she wouldn't say well and it's very
uncharacteristic for her just at the
last minute hey can you watch him i
gotta go and so i called her and
she was bawling and she you know so i
just kind of walked right into it it's
not
otherwise i don't think she would have
told me um
yeah she she did not has not told her
dad
because she's afraid of the
repercussions on that side but um
anyway but you're yeah i understand
where you're coming from and she has not
mentioned anything since about and i
haven't asked you know have y'all gotten
help have you seen it i just kind of
have backed out are you are you assuming
that she's staying in the marriage
i'm yes
it seems to me that they're working on
it and they want to get with better help
you know and he have a counselor and she
has a counselor action speak louder than
words sure
you know we'll see how that how that
plays out but yeah i believe she's
putting forth her best effort to to try
to work through it okay um last question
before i start walking into it have you
and your husband dealt with infidelity
of course across your marriage
um
we've been we've been divorced for 12
years when we were married no
no
not
my on my family my parents yes i have
lived through that so i think that's why
it's such a
poor subject for me you know
yeah
okay so
i'm assuming that they are working this
thing out
and that at this point your daughter has
the one that you feel confident you
raised wells good young mom he's got a
good head on her shoulder that she has
looked at this situation in her life and
said
this is a relationship that i want to
continue to invest in good for her okay
yeah um
any sort of trying to get in between
that her and that decision
um
i don't it's just an opportunity to
drive a wedge into some relationship and
i just don't see any value in it okay
um right the second thing is
you said he was sick is he even does he
struggle with addiction is he like why
do you say he's sick
because the manner in the way this
happened and how she found out it's like
basically he
contacted a prostitute but didn't have
to pay her i mean this is not someone he
had a
emotional connection with or worked with
and i mean it just came out of the blue
from what she understands and
she was saying you know mom that's sick
that's sick and i said yeah it is it is
sick he's sick he needs he needs help
okay
um i feel like he's got some alcohol
dependency um okay
but that's not me to speak into you know
yeah um
if there's um
if there is addiction issues that are
making your daughter and your grandchild
unsafe it is yours to speak into okay
so the way i i frame this is not by your
hand but in your lap you didn't cause
any of this but your daughter called you
she brought you into this
and i'm gonna keep my grandchild safe
i'm gonna keep my daughter safe and if
she chooses to stay with this guy
then i'm going to model what healthy
relationships look like and healthy
relationships do not have elephants in
rooms
they don't have secrets and they forgive
and like you mentioned they set bricks
down
and they lean in relationally
and so in my head i'm trying to think
through if this is my my daughter and
this happens with her husband
and she calls me and says well you keep
our baby i gotta go deal with my husband
and then i call her and say what's wrong
and she's weeping and now i'm brought
into this thing yes i'm gonna be pissed
off i'm gonna have to deal with my own
issues that's for me as a grown-up to
deal with myself right right um so i'm
gonna go have my friends in my community
if i gotta reach out to council i'm
gonna do that myself
but when it comes to the relationship
um i would sit down with a young man
and say
i got brought into this so here we are
you hurt my daughter and you violated
our trust in our family you threw a
grenade here
and
she's choosing to stay
which means you're a part of my life now
and that means i would probably do
something symbolic for a young man in
this situation like put it on a brick
and put tape on it like masking tape on
it and write it down cheated on my
daughter
so he could see it
and say when she called me that night
i've been carrying this around because
it hurt me i lived through this in my
family and my all that right
and then the symbolic and from this
point forward i'm setting it down
but here's what setting it down is going
to look like you and me are gonna have
breakfast together or you and me are
gonna like i'm going to lean into this
discomfort in the relationship and i'll
tell you if you tell him i feel like
every time we're in the same room
together there's some awkwardness
i'm the mother-in-law so i'll own it
but i want to get to know you
and we're going to spend some i want to
spend some time with you so i'm going to
reach out and i want to go do denny's
breakfast once a week or if they live
too far away then we're gonna fill in
the blank
but
i want him to see
he violated this thing
and but he's still gonna be a part of
your life and so i'm going to lean in on
the healing part of it and you can do
the good parent thing
and say and if you ever hurt my daughter
again right you know i'm a person with
special skills they'll never find that
kind of thing
yeah and you've got a wink at him but
um but i think there's something about
if you're interested in healing the
relationship and i get that from you
you're interested in healing this thing
you just don't know what's next
avoidance never works
right um secrets destroy families
unhad conversations destroy families now
your daughter could come to you and say
please god almighty do not mention
anything to him
don't talk to him don't bring it up it
can't happen
and i would push her on that because she
brought you into this
yeah and she might even say that i'm
never going to tell you again you could
say great great that's fine yeah you
told me about this one
yeah
and if he's going to be in my house and
i want to invest in this relationship
because it's a part of your life
the sucky thing about boundaries is that
other people can use them too
right okay and they can use them to cut
you out just as much as you can say
here's what's gonna how my house is
gonna look like
i hope that isn't the case here
hopefully he
is really repentant and remorseful and
is getting help that he needs and also
can be changed over time
by the love of his mother-in-law maybe
the first time somebody's reached out
and loved him
other than yeah
not in a romantic way
yeah yeah
yeah but holy smokes that'll be hard
right
man
yeah you know the your kids are young
the mama bear doesn't go away when they
become adults no no no there's some
great research on women and aggression
and especially with your kids
like men get the uh aggression stuff all
the time in the popular media but like
man
yeah mama bear dude that's for real
that's right that's for real
yeah yeah
so okay well this has been very helpful
how does that sound
good i i think um
yeah just sitting down with them and how
you approached it that hey i got brought
into this and and um
like i said i don't want to guilt him or
shame him because i feel like he's
living enough of that right now um
he's very remorseful and i don't want to
throw darts at him
uh that would not be helpful at all so
if you're trying to help somebody not
live in shame
um
the only way to not live in shame is to
turn the lights on and have vulnerable
relationships
yeah and yeah like what is it rene brown
says shame eat secrets for breakfast
that's what fuels shame and so we're not
gonna do this and the path to freedom
for him is some really uncomfortable
conversations with people he hurt
and those people saying
and i see all of you and i still love
you
and i see all of you and now you got to
go to breakfast with me once a week
yeah
and it may be so awkward stay on the
line i'm going to send you all of them
every pack of conversations with with
humans uh cards that we have
i'm gonna send you guys
awesome but here's the deal yeah you can
use them and you can say i got these
stupid cards for us to learn how to not
to learn you don't say anything just say
hey i got these cards and we're gonna go
to breakfast until we go through every
one of these decks the ones for work the
ones for couples that's going to get
weird between me and you right
i think that would be a great way to get
to know this guy
yeah and yeah that would be yeah he may
hurt your daughter again and you can
tell them you got you got you've you've
played your card now
okay yeah the next time you hurt my
daughter the next time you violate our
trust her trust as a family that you
um
it's gonna be a different conversation
than we have okay or my boundaries will
look different and that's okay to have
hard boundaries and accountability and
all that kind of stuff i think that's
really important
yeah yeah i don't think she would say if
it happened again that's why when i
talked to her i explained to her your
scenario about the twin towers and you
know
some tournaments
yeah and it may be that he's not working
five hours from home anymore but part of
that is a new job and a part of that is
new all every everything's got to be
different now and everything's gonna be
on the table they may have to move away
and go do live somewhere else
everything's on the table now right when
you're rebuilding after infidelity
especially in a young marriage with a
young kid everything's different now and
great good cool awesome
the thing you can control on all that is
you and um even sitting with your
daughter i'd recommend you sit down with
her and have a hard conversation um
tell let her know that you'll be there
for her let her know that she needs to
get close compadres and friends and
community and
um you need to have a conversation with
this guy and all that and moving forward
but um
that's a tough i'm just thinking through
that man my blood boils just thinking
about that and hopefully my daughter's
not married for a long long time and
hopefully she never experiences that
um but the data tells me she might
and man
all of us have hard conversations
we have to look in the mirror before we
have and say
what's our goal of this conversation and
how can we bring about both boundaries
and
healing
man this guy's lucky to have you this is
mother-in-law he won the lottery we'll
see you soon